how's it going bros my name why you
always want to know getting them all -
yeah you made another one I like its
face oh oh
I tried me today okay so I'm controlling
this how I don't know attend hey
but he just wanted to catch last BAM
done with this [ __ ] I don't want to do
it again I'm dodging I'm coming anyway
what are you doing
he's crazy place readied my awesome
finger what is it hey crazy they have
legs so just once
Oh kiss come and the legs are set there
we go
kill all sounds a [ __ ] ash that's right
that's how I Brown hey heads up falling
penises are crawling and everyone is
dead I did it spike fall that has two
pluses in front of it hey Kyle are you
goes in this see me rollin they hatin
mode directly I wish I could stay in it
patrolling and trying to catch me riding
I'm just gonna do it this time later
[ __ ] that was not as I wanted it all
right no I think this would be perfect
yeah leg go far you're going red spot
damn don't leave me I'm gonna finish
this one we can do a dress I'm a potato
apparently yeah too little speed hey no
leg don't leave me
thank you god damn it here we go don't
leave Vespa that's that's a key in this
game there we go come on
it is easy there we go not the problem
we did it I became a ketchup bottle but
I best but ah together forever
I hate you I guess I got it best I came
back oh thank you we're together forever
huh Marius oh what a beautiful landing
here with a head and their vest but
everyone reunited it's a beautiful love
story so so pumped for the next I shut
up god damn it whoa do you shut up too
got them on JB's [ __ ] forgot he's
humping my dad all right ha ha god damn
it chick my arms tight Oh hmm nice
nothing bad watch what easy ha ha yes
yes oh you think you can [ __ ] with me
you're right you're so wrong eat this
that's right oh but to help going to
pass whoa I'll be good again I get me
yes I think I said you know I because
you don't care yes you're so right well
done son I don't care about anything
here we go boss do you want from a bus
man just gotta get it oh sorry
talk about your twin [ __ ] yeah yeah
nothing boss check her jealous oh you're
my twin right oh that's right
[ __ ] you up
yeah you see this [ __ ] son dad you're so
awesome
I know [ __ ] no that's how I roll
that's how I get all the ladies special
man rescue it's your duty to keep Gothic
cities alright lady what did you do
catch me catch me a fish no never back
off with your samurai sorry
alright here we go hey what is this oh
you tricked me
why control having died oh nice jump
sorry yeah I'm sorry take me I like it
yes spin it right then stop at Best Buy
don't cheat on me right in front - bah
what are you doing I like it I [ __ ]
love it
bad spot stop this nonsense that's right
the only might that's bad come on I love
it love it I love it
come on you can jump over me anytime you
want best passion not right now there we
go
[ __ ] ah I'm not gonna take Nick all
right hey you made it
have no idea what the [ __ ] what's going
on a drivable Kirby dah [ __ ] I'm reading
music for this one for sure I love this
bike get that dad dad dad I know that
what static Santa what are you doing in
huh baby so much
[Music]
is too awesome
[Music]
and you're alive can you make it alright
whatever
ah this is gonna be difficult
right in my head
taste elation you see that [ __ ] how they
shook her on this never ever that I
don't know why I said that's okay come
on ha and a front step to the wind and a
comfortable position far they even
double win
you know what I think it's about time we
played some Peter perhaps it's not as
tough a Tunisian did daddy get even
close to him you wake up what what is
this thing but what is that well Shabana
I lost baby Jesus Christ I mean whoa
backflip yeah yeah synchronize damn
yeah synchronize dance yeah yeah yeah
yeah uncle [ __ ] what'd you say I like
that song I don't care right maybe we
can whoa
don't trust the father like that then
you can make the Sun go away well yeah
whatever all right let's go
Alice baby whoa you baka baka god damn
it I'm with the father now
Alice yeah yeah hey Perry yeah yeah I'm
poor
okay but I'm trying to get past you know
dad
this man is epic Oh God if we couldn't
be anybody we have a [ __ ] man cat pee
I love you all right this yes not gonna
kill me all right
paddy be careful I don't trust that oh I
[ __ ] knew it
it's bad this [ __ ] that thank you say
replay
alright marry with Savannah well done
well done guess they learned their
lesson oh my god oh my god don't tell me
I can write him I'm reading you as a
backpack problem problem boom that's
right that's how I ride it I got your
[ __ ] penis oh it's your hand
you got [ __ ] penis hands that's what
you get for talking to me well I want
him to grab him but I think I'd be like
Segway guy or something like that
alright here we go bigger yeah ah oh I
didn't go well
gah [ __ ] yeah I'm pump a punt I'm 60 and
I know eh well yeah piggy calm down huh
- ed there's no stopping this sexy
[ __ ]
oh yeah hump me piggy PT yeah help me
all night long no I ever see what some
more fun that pink it was awesome
alright
yeah braids are dad [ __ ] yeah
oh yeah [ __ ]
haters gonna [ __ ] hate
[Music]
laughs my legs does it even matter
I'm on a [ __ ] sheet a [ __ ] hey it's
got a semen on my order down well night
hello is head-banging like yeah [ __ ] am
i doing I'm a chief dangerous no front
flat can't even do it
[Music]
alright I think ever that is here so
like and favorite if you enjoyed the sky
covered Road today and I'll see you next
episode that's pretty much it
I don't want to really help you
[Music]
okay
[Music]
and I your let out shut